ich bin derzeit in elternzeit habe vor
vier monaten meine tochter bekommen und
wollte unbedingt einen beheizten
aufblasbare whirlpool für uns beide
bestehen wo wir ein bisschen planschen
können da der in bekannten baumärkten
schon ausverkauft war habe ich gegoogelt
und bin auf die seite www pult us tisch
punkt.de gestoßen
ich habe mit vorkasse bezahlt auf ein
spanisches konto bei der spanische u
bahn und den pool leider nie erhalten
es ist so dass mir sonst auf der seite
wirklich nichts komisch vorkam die seite
war ganz normal aufgebaut
ich habe eine ganz normale rechnung
bekommen ja die polizei hat uns sogar
sage ich mal die hoffnung genommen da
irgendwas machen zu können
das gerät ist leider food bereich
einfach wurde sich dargestellt habe und
dann jeden vielen dank fürs zuhören hieß
ja schön dass sie frau engelbrecht sich
an uns gewandt hat damit waren sie
natürlich auch andere zuschauer
das ist wohl dieser typische fake shop
an kempkens also der typische fake shop
und da ist es ganz wichtig dass man wenn
man den vertrag schließt dass man ins
impressum cook das hat sich immer so ein
bisschen so wie das die die spießige
anwalts tipps tipps an wenn man sagt
bitte guckt auch ins impressum
man muss eins sagen wenn schon kein
vernünftiges impressum da ist also der
geschäftsführer steht mit einer
anschrift mit einer telefonnummer
wenn da schon nicht gegeben ist dann ist
schon irgendwas faul oder kann
jedenfalls größtenteils ausbau seien
kinder davon lassen wenn das impressum
da ist dann kann man auch mal die
einzelnen personen die da genannt werden
beispielsweise der geschäftsführer den
kann man bei google und kann mal gucken
gibt es da schon bewertung über den hat
er schon mal ähnliche shops gemacht das
ist meistens der fall wenn man aber den
geschäfts oder gar nicht googeln kann
denn es den gar nicht gibt dann auch
eher die finger davon lassen denn alle
unternehmen die ja ich sag mal
nennenswert am markt platziert sind und
die seriös sind die werden auch irgendwo
erwähnt und die kann man auch wieder
finden das nicht wieder fit ist ein ganz
schlechtes zeichen und wenn man dann
hier wie in diesem fall in spanien wenn
hier etwas getauft wurde ist natürlich
unheimlich schwer da was zu machen dann
müssten wir nach spanien gehen und das
funktioniert tatsächlich nur mit
spanischen anwältin also von deutschland
aus
eigentlich unmöglich